Hey David, what is worse after what happened
in Iowa this last week?
The electoral college or the caucus system,
which is more broken?
Well.
What's interesting about the electoral college
system and the caucus system is that aside
from the ways in which they leave themselves
open to manipulation, that's not what I'm
going to deal with today.
They're kind of broken in the same way.
I mean one.
So with Iowa, the complaints came around,
you know, the app that was used, the reporting,
the sketchy way in which, how wasn't it tested
fully?
Like we get all that stuff.
But really when it comes down to it, Bernie
Sanders won the popular vote in Iowa, but
did not get the most number of delegates.
That is a similar problem to winning the popular
vote nationally and not winning the electoral
college.
Hillary Clinton winning by several million
votes and Donald Trump's still winning the
electoral college.
The problems are very similar.
They're broken in very a similar ways.
Now you can argue that the caucus system is
less obviously a disaster at a state level
because you can conceivably still handle an
election at the state level under that caucus
system, which would just be absolute and total
chaos nationally.
But that's not what we're comparing.
We're comparing caucuses and States and the
electoral college system nationally.
I think that the electoral college system
has had more of an impact in elections.
If you look at the number now of Republican
presidents who have won electorally but lost
the popular vote, that is a system that has
handed numerous presidencies to the Republican
party.
When you look at the caucus system in States,
there's no question that between the coin
flips and winning the popular vote, but losing
the delegate count at the state level, there
have been a effects from having the caucus
system, but as far as I was able to research
going back about 30 years, the caucus system
has not flipped.
Who ultimately was the nominee in the democratic
party.
Super delegates had been a big part of that.
That's separate from the caucus system.
You can look at that as something that has
actually changed the outcome of who is the
democratic nominee, but the caucus system
has not flipped the results in the way that
the electoral system, nationally has giving
the presidency to multiple Republicans who
actually lost the popular vote.
So if you asked me, which has been worse in
terms of its impact, I have to say that it's
the electoral system changing either or.
Both has its quirks, of course, States often,
uh, although debt, although the democratic
and Republican parties are not government
institutions and they can run their primary
however they want, States often have laws
about when their primary is or how it works.
So New Hampshire has to be the first primary.
Iowa has to be the first to vote at least
eight days before any primary, which is why
February 3rd was the day of the Iowa caucus,
and eight days later, February 11th is the
day a was the day of the New Hampshire primary.
So you can change that at the state level
to get rid of the electoral college system.
Of course, you would either need a constitutional
amendment or it could happen to facto through
something called the NPV icy national popular
vote interstate compact States can decide
unilaterally how to award their electoral
votes and a state, for example, Texas could
say, we don't care which candidate wins Texas.
We're going to give our delegates to the winner
of the national popular vote.
If you get enough States to do that, that
they some 270 electoral votes, you create
a de facto national popular vote that seems
by far the most viable and likely way we could
get a national popular vote.
You are not going to see, you know when you've
got to have a two thirds vote in the Senate
and three quarters of the States say, let's
get rid of the electoral college.
All of the red States that know that they've
had multiple presidencies handed to them by
the electoral college, they're not going to
do it.
So something like the NPV IC would really
be the only likely way that I see of getting
rid of the electoral college and switching
to a national popular vote.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show today.
Instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member@joinpacman.com or a patron at patrion.com/david
package, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].